[Music]
replicas is a film that I've been
interested in for quite a while due to
my love of Keanu Reeves as an actor he's
really been on his third career revival
since John wick and he's just one of my
favorites however for the past month
I've been hearing mixed things about his
new film replicas and after its release
was pushed to January things didn't seem
good I'm happy to say though that
replicas is an enjoyable if slightly
flawed film the biggest of those floors
being the lackluster CGI which bogs down
the film every time one of the Androids
appears on screen this seems to be where
the main criticism of the film lies
across the board and personally I did
have a really fun ride with it what I
love about the movie is that Reeves and
bodies Makaveli in mind stay and as we
watch the film he crosses the line
several times in order to restore what
he once had with his family there's a
really heartbreaking moment in the movie
and I was shocked to actually see come
to fruition and it will certainly stay
with me for many years to come
Reeves does a great job of portraying an
antihero who though we know is ethically
wrong still side with watching him
tumble down the rabbit hole is fantastic
and this puts him in increasingly more
difficult situations at the core of
replicas is a question of if you were
able to bring back your loved ones would
you and to me that's a very
thought-provoking question that I spent
time debating with long after I left the
theater sure this isn't perfect and
there are a lot of films out there that
cover this estate better than replicas
but I still enjoyed it and I think that
most audiences will too overall I had a
lot of fun with replicas and that's why
I get a 7 out of 10 make sure you leave
your thoughts on the film in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then be sure to like it and check
out my video which discusses the film's
ending which will be linked after this
one this is the channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I've seen
take care peace
[Music]